so I'm gonna be giving two talks to
start that first I'm going to focus a
give a brief talk focusing on the data
repository and then I'm gonna be talking
about the resource system in general and
yeah by learning by the data repository
will make more sense what exactly we
mean by the resource system and then I
will hand things over to Megan who will
talk specifically about neural nets so
so to start off what's the motivation
for the data repository so there are
lots of other data repositories or
repositories online if you search you
can find them easily but a lot of them
struggle struggle do the same problems
say there's no standards across the
datasets basically if you have data to
publish you can you can add it to their
site and they'll make a web page where
people can download it but then there's
no real easy way for anybody to know how
to use it with different file formats
different data structures there's no
examples that show you how to how to use
that because the the repositories
weren't actually set up to actually be
used with any user mind they were just
sort of created so that the publishers
of the data could say that they've
published your data before they submit
it to a journal but that did Wolfram
data repository solves these problems it
because we have the power of the Wolfram
language and the Wolfram cloud behind us
so all the data is in the consistent
framework the Wolfram data framework and
it's easy to access and use immediately
from any Wolfram language environment so
what is the data repository so this sort
of breaking down the pieces of it
there's there's a website front-end to
it that you can explore the data in and
immediately start using it
there are Wolfram language functions to
integrate
to integrate the data into the Wolfram
language there's the back end of the
data repository lives within our clouds
so all of this is you know using our own
technology to create to create the data
repository so it's got hosted data and
api's and then there's the content of
course the most important part what's in
there and we have a great group of
people that are dedicated to finding
data you know we with the experience
that we had from developing rule form
alpha we had a lot of you know
experience within our staff of knowing
how to get data and make it computable
so we took advantage of that and we have
a great data set that's always expanding
so the in this talk we can look at
serving increasingly sophisticated use
cases for the data repository first
we're just going to look at the website
so we're poke around at it which might
be the first thing that you want to do
second we're going to access resources
from the Wolfram language and you know
import the data and use it
the third thing we're gonna do is we're
going to create our own data resource
and then the last thing we're gonna do
is see how you can submit data for
publication so just start off we can
look at the website so this is the home
page of the data repository website you
can see that the data we have broken
down into two dimensions categories like
what you know history and geography and
then the type so you know you can have
time series data about human activities
or you can have graph data about social
media so these are sort of two different
dimensions that were that we stored data
along you can search for for keywords or
you can you can learn more about how to
use the data repository at any of these
links but let's just go ahead and find
find an interesting data set so here we
have governmental data some of this is
from data gov some of it is
other state or local or international
governments so we can just pick one of
these how about a Liam the police
department crime data so when we go to
one of these you see a few features you
can see the title make this a little bit
bigger for some of you you can see the
title a brief description a brief
summary of how big the data is and one
thing that's nice is you can immediately
open this example notebook here in in
our cloud I'm going to show how to use
it and desktop instead but but it would
be the same experience for those of you
who are cloud users and what's great
about this is right immediately after we
have this we have examples on how to use
it you can click one of these things and
go straight back into your notebook and
just paste it in here and you'll get the
same thing you'll see it's downloading
to do sometimes these things can take a
minute to display okay there we go so so
you're right off and running with with
the data you can if I say theta equal
this this percent means I'm setting the
class result to data and you know you
can do these things immediately you can
say you know take largest by beat looks
like a numeric value let's see how that
does just take the first 10 and stay
geolocation so there we have those and I
can say geo list plot of that and and
I'll get a map right away so all of this
is computable and it's all like I said
the Wolfram data framework so it's all
compatible with every language in the
Wolfram language we can look at another
example that are prepared beforehand
doing the same sort of thing grab
grabbing a data set picking a random
sample from it
to display there we go so now now we're
gonna find find the value in here that
has a look at the weather station has
the largest rain total in January I can
I can take the largest one and then just
give me the coordinates of it if I want
to do that for all the months not just
January I can get the months this way
and then map this take largest by this
hash map is applying it to all those
months so I can do that now I have my
coordinates I can get wrap them in this
geo marker which is which is a just a
graphical tool for making these little
markers and just like that in a few
lines you know all in this just one line
of code that I've built up by
sequentially doing different steps this
one line of code makes this a nice nice
map showing us the weather station with
the largest rainfall for each month of
the year so in addition to just grabbing
the data all of these all the data lives
within these resource objects so this
resource object accident sort of a
pointer to the data but it also contains
metadata so if you want to see what the
metadata fields are you can look at
properties so all these are all the
metadata fields associated with this
resource you see my categories in our
science to meteorology I can look at the
source that originally created the data
if it's from a publication and you can
look at what the different what the
content of the element is so in addition
to the data that we already saw which
was dataset there are other content
elements within the resource so we
already looked at the data set let's we
can also look at another element which
is the column description so so you know
in addition to the primary data there's
also these additional things that can
come with each resource so you can
search resources we saw that there was a
search field on the website this is
basically doing the same thing but it
will also include
any resources that I've created myself
so we have a bunch of them that we've
labeled a sample because they're sort of
just various or almost trivial datasets
so if I pick a random random one of
those airplane glass let's see what
that's about time to failure so this is
some sort of statistical data set for
material science or civil engineering I
guess and now you can get the give the
data just like that so this is a small
one if that's why that's why I say all
the sample data so so that's serve how
you just start using the published
resources within the Wolfram language
the next step up in sophistication is if
you want to create your own resources so
you can create your own resources two
ways you can do it programmatically like
this so you just use resource object and
you type in this association this
association was new in version 10 of the
Wolfram language in it key value map so
you can define all of your properties
and you can define what the content is
so here I've created a resource object
with data that then I can immediately
start using it just like you know as if
it was from the public repository right
so Wolfram Alpha knows knows how old you
are this is this is our audience here
the the the nicer way to make one of
these things is using what we call the
definition notebook so this is the
definition of book in here instead of
filling this out in an association you
can you can type in your name and your
description and you can tell it where if
you're kind where your content is or you
can put the content in it you can create
examples I'm not going to take the time
to fill one out here from scratch but
I've filled one out beforehand sort of
like a cooking show right I got one
already in the oven and so here we have
a definition notebook that's been filled
out we make this a little bigger for you
and what I did was I went to this
website which has
at baseball statistics and I just yeah
we'll look at it I just top I just
copied this guy just like this just grab
it on like that and did a copy paste and
I'd add this tab delimited data and I'm
using semantic import string which works
on that I tell it what each column of
data is supposed to be when it gives me
this nice data set that I can use I can
define the data just go through here
evaluate evaluating the cells that have
the little wolf's next to them I've
created examples and that I want to be
in my example notebook and then here
this dollar dollar resource object line
turns all the content of this notebook
into a resource object so here I have my
resource object and I can use it just
like I used it here if all I care about
is sort of having something to use
locally I can cache it so that it'll be
available next time I you know if I quit
if I quit the Wolfram language it'll be
available again later or what's fun is I
can deploy this to my my cloud account
so here I've done this and now I have
this nice webpage showing showing the
name and description just like in the
public repository and it has these
examples so you can take this since I
made said this one was public I could
take this one and send it to you know my
colleagues or I can post it on my blog
or whatever I want and anybody can use
my resource object themselves in Wolfram
cloud or Mathematica or anything else
and then the last thing I can do is
submit this to be included in the public
repository and that we're going to talk
about more in the in the next talk about
how you can do submissions as far as
publisher accounts because it requires a
publisher account we'll talk about that
in the in the next talk but as far as
what we want in the data repository if
you're interested in
your data published in our data
repository we definitely like things
from you know academic publications you
know or anything that's really well
vetted generally interesting data in
addition to those sort of like really
nice data sets that have that have been
that are from established or since we're
also looking for sample data like the
one I showed you with the the glass
tensile test or whatever it was and so
so if you have a sample data that we
don't already have represented within
our data repository we're interested in
that as well and you need to make sure
they have to attribute it to the
originator if it's you that's great if
it's not you that's fine you just need
to make sure that you tell us who
originally came up with it and show us
that you have the rights to it and you
need to have a nicely written
description of what it is and why people
are interested in it the data should be
in the Wolfram data framework like I've
mentioned a couple times now so should
have things like quantities and entities
and data objects and geo positions and
how to take data from you know your your
colleagues Excel spreadsheet or some
some other source and get it into wdf is
sort of beyond the scope of this talk
but Erin Enright well from employee has
done great great demonstrations of how
to do that walking through real examples
and turning them into computable data
and he live broadcasts those on Twitch
and the twitch videos are available
these links or you can use these QR
codes right now if you want to if you
want to get your smartphone out real
quick give you a couple seconds but
don't don't start watching that and stop
watching me it would be a mistake
so that that is sort of the summary of
data repository which is the first
repository in our resource system and so
the next talk I'm going to move on to in
a minute is about the resource system in
general and all the other repositories
that we have but before we move on I can
go ahead and
take any questions that you might have
about the data repository